Bụi khó khảo hành quốc, người mình tạm thương mề mồ tuyên bụi lên án vụ chêu tiên phòng tên lợi đảm đạo.
Già vùng biển thế đông trước đó mức ngày, kêu gọi biển dưỡng giất các hành động làm ra tăng tăng hành lên chêu.
Trong bảo cao, xe un đông thời gmer tỏ lấy làm tiếp trước được chêu tiên chỉ trích cuộc tập trận trung và hội nghị án hình thường miêng của bộ lối đồng mình Mỹ hạn.
Trong rằng lợi lệ này, người tổn hại nỗ lực vý trí đối thoại và ổn định khu vực.
Trước đó, cùng ngày bụi trường có phòng trường tiên nỗ quang trò bên bố,
nương này sẽ thực hiện các hành động tấn tông mạnh mê hơn.
Nông thời lên án của gặp dựa cá bụi trường có phòng miêng của hành quốc tải khu phía quân sự.
Cúc như việc tạo xin vai trẻ mặng lượng hành nhanh TUSS,
Edge George Washington của Mỹ, tập cảng buồn dân, ông nương gọi cho động thái trên đã mục lộ gió bản chất thủ đệ của lên mình Mỹ hạn.
Và phía Mỹ, bụi trình tránh hành định qua hệ nông mình về hành quốc và tập trung vào việc dân đề bình yếu,
trong khi bộ từ lại đánh đổ dường thái bình dường cho biết vô phòng tiên lượng mới của chếp tiên mặc dù không đe gió à chế tiếp,
sau lạm lỗi bất cả tà đợp người gái mở ở định của cú vực.